oh yeah so i have a question for uh
sorry how do i sound concerned
you
mentioned that you need the
cheating to be independent of
intervention yes and that might be
slightly i don't know it seems slightly
problematic for the particular setup you
have but do you think there are other
experiments where that might be slightly
more plausible or so that's the question
for you and for anish you mentioned that
you
[Music]
you found like modeling conditions under
which
linear model from one intervention can
be transferred to another intervention
and are there like have you thought
about when can the convex combination
model like the synthetic control can
that be transferred across interventions
so those are the two questions
thanks for the question so it's
something that we thought deeply about
trying to get rid of that assumption
it's somewhat i wouldn't say
mathematically necessary but so the
designs that we're thinking about are
you know like how some a b testing they
would change the pixel by a couple of
inches or like change the color by a
little bit in some ui related designs in
those cases and especially in
interventions of those type we think uh
this this uh blinding essentially of
treatment because if the participant is
not aware of which arm they're in
then there's no way that the cheating
participator could actually use that
leverage that information so that's
where we think it's plausible uh in the
case of our data set yeah this is
something that we talk about is that it
is possible that because when they enter
the trial they know what type of thing
that they will see
and so it is possible that they might be
using that information to maybe cheat in
a different way if they saw a video or
even person video versus not but it's
hard to understand yeah it'll be i need
to talk to education expert about how
the cheating mechanism would work
so like you said when
when the user cannot really
differentiate between the intervention
then would there be a
will there'll be a different outcome
like i feel like isn't that a concern
too like you said if there are blind
some small pixels that the user cannot
perceive then will there be a difference
in the outcome to begin with is there a
very small difference but a lot of these
uh tech uh a b testing enrolls a lot of
participants so actually given enough
sample size you'll be actually able to
detect if there is any difference uh
so we think that's uh so some of the
citations that we mentioned about the
uber trying this and google trying this
they're essentially doing these kind of
things changing the font side by a
little bit moving the front of the
center versus left and so we think it's
in those settings because we don't even
know we might be in a bucket for trying
these things we don't even know if
they're not trading our controller and
so those cases were blinded so even if
i'm a cheater i wouldn't be able to use
that information because i don't know
what the assignment was
the linearity shows up because of i'm
assuming that
the
target units factor lies in the linear
span of the other people if i now
replace that with saying it lies in the
convex span then convexity is a natural
thing to do
but with if you have a low rank model
then almost by definition
a linear span inclusion must hold
you don't have a lin let's say r is
actually very large
in that case may be the case that a
linear model is not sufficient to
describe the relationship but maybe some
polynomial of that is
so likely one reason to maybe instead of
getting a linear model fit
some polynomial of the of the donor
group outcomes
the error in variables gets a lot harder
when you have polynomials um
yeah and but you can also prove i think
this is nothing you're doing where if
you're saying that the things are being
sampled independently from a bounded
space and actually the high probability
you'll have other people that are close
enough to you right so then even the
nearest neighbor style thing but not
convex but uniform weights might work so
it kind of depends on what assumptions
you're willing to make on exactly that
assumption
and
it's my turn
[Laughter]
so i also have a couple questions for
hong song i'm sorry no that's perfectly
fine
um
[Music]
so one kind of easy one you talked a lot
about data fusion would you be able to
do data fusion if you had
um data sets with different epsilons
and the other question is about the
independence assumption could you use
like the rosenbaum muhammad type of
sensitivity to do robustness checks to
violate yeah so those are thank you for
those uh for the first question about
whether we can combine two data sets of
different epsilons yes it is possible
just we have to adjust the r and the r
prime and the identification a little
differently but we can adjust them and
then we can just kind of it's
effectively weighted averaging between
the one estimate from one differential
private and the other one
as long as we know that this data set
came from that epsilon parameter and
this other data set came with different
epsilon parameters you can adjust
accordingly the second question about
the independence assumption that yeah so
this is the direction that we were
thinking about before we wrote it up and
then put an archive and submitted it we
did i mean it is something that we're
definitely exploring the thing is it's
hard to have a sensitivity parameter for
cheating and it's not entirely clear
we're kind of brainstorming what will be
the right sensitivity parameter that's
interpretable but at the same time i
also reveal something useful about the
null effect or not not not present so
this is something i'll be happy to chat
with you about if you're more interested
but something that we're kind of
brainstorming at the moment
um so i have a follow-up question it's
also on the the definition of sheetings
and the assumption
so
let's say that you have someone who is
reluctant to it doesn't believe that you
see the spinner perhaps and and would be
if been told to say something would
not follow that but it's told to say the
truth would be inclined to maybe do that
i don't know
but so
he's saying truth would that be that is
definitely cheater right because it
doesn't follow but would
would that have be ruled out under your
condition
because
like if it has if there is a treatment
effect for that unit right that would uh
depend on the on the treatment
assignment
uh that's a good question i i think so i
though
if the if the person is acting only on
the information about the spinner and
how he perceived the spinner
irrespective of and maybe he perceived
the spinner differently if he was a
given treatment versus if he was given
control then yes i then it would affect
the assumption and then the
identification becomes quite
questionable and sensitivity analysis
may be difficult but if the person is
acting on this uh the spinner
information the same way had he or she
seen the in the control or treatment
setting that would not affect our
identification result the key here is
that essentially as long as the cheater
starts to act on the treatment
information then it contaminates the
response how the behavior responds and
that essentially downstream has
downstream effects on identifying the
effects and so that's and we can't
correct there's no way to eliminate
those group of people if they
essentially start to mess around with
the outcome based on
the treatment side
and someone who is do you include
honesty in the in the in the blue
condition i don't forget what you call
it so
if i'm if i'm reluctant you're being
told to tell the uh the truth if i'm
reluctant to tell the truth would i be
considered to be a shooter in that
setting ah yes a cheater we define as to
be anyone who deviates uh in any any
fashion from the uh from the the spinner
protocol so if they only deviate if
they're on the that's in the blue circle
but not on the red and the green circle
then they'll still be a cheater because
they deviated from the original protocol
design so i think that a lot of these
settings there's worried that people
don't understand the design right so
they don't understand the differential
privacy kind of
properties of it so they don't
might not understand that they are
private right and that that would
potentially make a lot of people
cheaters right in there yes so that's
actually it came up in the irb
discussion the convincing the irp
officer
that you know what i would we see yes it
might not actually be yes and it might
be a no and a convincing yeah so that
it's it's it's an effort that we have to
take as we designed the experiment to
clearly explain this but yeah something
that we have to do from a more practical
angle yeah and so we would uh when
magician and i designed this child we
really thought hard about how to explain
this and we had a diagram we had another
explanation
yeah all these other things but it might
there might there are definite ways to
improve it for sure
so a comment down you only have one
woman teacher
so technically you only prove that
for a woman teacher because i mean
in person classroom students react very
differently to women teachers and male
teachers right oh believe that it also
transfers over to men
but technically you only have one
and then if you generalize to all
lectures that that's
so can you run more experiments yeah so
this is a great point so we we we were
the instructors that helped us
participate we were thinking about
whether we should include their their
faces and randomize the type of faces
that are being presented but that would
require more effort during covid and and
they weren't i mean they were really
already helpful enough so this yeah but
this is something that we need to think
about generalizability and the different
kinds of ways to do the instructor kind
of thing so
some current work we're trying to figure
this out and trying to design a more
clear way to tease out those effects
yeah i mean we actually want to think
about computer voices because that would
be more neutral but yeah and there's
different like variations of me yeah
yeah yeah yeah but yeah so
yeah a lot of discussion during cope it
happened over zoom actually
yeah i i've got a question for emma
it's about how you incorporate
background knowledge in with your cp dag
stuff so as i understand it the scenario
outlined for us was one whereby
you have some data you learn a cp deck
from said data using your favorite cp
daggering algorithm
and then you
consult your background knowledge and
say oh hang on i've got some background
knowledge here so i can orient some ages
which
maybe i
wouldn't be able to worry otherwise but
one thing that occurs to me when you
learn your cp dag some of those edges
will be oriented
and maybe what could happen is that
you're then going to consult your
background knowledge and say oh that's
the wrong way around that orientation so
will it not be better to incorporate the
background knowledge in the learning
process rather than post hoc
great question uh yes
so the short answer is yes you can do it
the other way around so there are
certain implementations of these
algorithms that allow you to do that not
all of them though a lot of them only do
it kind of post hoc
and i guess there the question would be
like how much do you trust your
background knowledge versus data
uh in kind of what order you would want
to do or like you know which maybe you
want to drop or or not
um but yes yes so either way is is fine
with respect to the results
as long as you kind of have an
algorithm that does it
so like the tetrad i think
implementation will allow you to add it
like pre
learning the cp dive
i think the pc implementation in pcr
will not let you will let you do some
things pre but not all of the things
but it can be modified to allow it
but it's not there yet so
that's it
yeah so
uh i have two questions so one for the
cp tag work the other for the private
rcd work so let me go the cpdac first
so you assume that you know the cpdac
meaning the buckets and the chain graph
that connects the buckets right
so if you run an observational discovery
algorithm
like ges and stuff um of course that
would be nice
uh so my question is end to end uh
although it is technically identifiable
if i finally ask the question is your
final estimator still the lowest
variance
uh taking the whole process into account
is there anything that we can say about
it or have you run some empirical
estimate experiments to end to end to
see if the whole thing works that's my
question so let me also complete the
second question for the private uh
so uh from what i understand from your
theorem statement you say that you offer
protection
i mean differential privacy guarantees
for the non-cheaters uh cheaters anyway
you cannot do anything
um so looking at it from a membership
attack from point of view because what
is differential privacy guarantee right
the only thing it guarantees against an
attack model the attack model is a
membership attack model so if i knew
something about you from some other
source
i must not be able to say that you were
present in that cohort right so that's a
rough idea for the motivation
now the problem here is if i am a
cheater
and i want protection for my identity
would that be offered in your rct is my
question
okay not that it's desirable but
but suppose if i wanted
i want to cheat but i don't want anybody
else to know yeah
uh yeah sure i can i can answer this the
cbd question first so uh for us it's
true we start with kind of assuming we
know the graph and then based on this
information i tell you like what is the
best estimator right
so
if you were to learn the graph and you
didn't make any mistakes in terms of the
causal kind of orientations missing
edges present edges
then you know this would still be the
best thing to do
and we did some simulations to kind of
see how we compare against other methods
when you estimate the whole process
and
generally we still do better though our
results are asymptotic right so it's
like
sample versus
if you make errors in your learning the
graph process which you probably will
make
then that will definitely affect kind of
what will be the optimal estimator
because we're starting from this
assumption that the graph we have is the
correct one right it's the correct
equivalence class graph and if it's not
uh then pro there could be other things
that are
that are better so i will say that in
kind of the process of working with
richard on like this generalizing it to
the
nonparametric setting
we do kind of see that perhaps some
mistakes in the graph do not influence
uh but
it's very particular types of kind of
mistakes that do not influence
efficiency in india
um yeah i guess that's my answer
for your answer about yeah it's another
great question that we also thought
about during the design stage so what
our theorem suggests is that you
shouldn't cheat because if they cheat
then
because we don't make any for the
differential privacy and we don't make
any assumptions about the cheater how
they respond to treatment so if they're
clever cheaters but they actually just
report what the opposite of their
response then technically you can attack
it and then actually discover it if you
consistently know this pattern so what
our theorem suggests is that maybe you
should be honest when it comes to these
things uh but you know there's the
there's we also to work on this
communicating this that it is
differentiate private what differentiate
your privacy means and actually we spent
quite a bit of time when you design this
trial to actually try to convince this
idea but we're not entirely super
successful but it's something else
something that we need to definitely
work on in that area
[Music]
this actually we spent a lot more time
convincing the rv officer to release the
individual data and based on that
experience we think we need a better way
to do this actually
um so i have a question uh for hunt
i have
two so yeah i can ask the first one and
that's the second one after
that's a good or order
um
so
i guess one of the things i was thinking
about is
you know if you do
covariate adjust adjustment
then if you want to replicate if i want
to replicate your results
i need to have the covariates in my hand
and
you know the cobarians themselves could
be private
you you might want to be
privatizing this maybe you have to add
some laplacian noise or do whatever
kinds of mechanisms one wants to do
uh
on the other hand
like if we want designs that try to have
some covariate balance or depend on the
covariance in some way if i want to
replicate your results if i want to
like do a variance estimation let's say
i have to know
certain types of inclusion
probabilities or correlations between
treatment assignments
and if the design
depends on the covariance i can learn
the covariates or i can learn at least
i think i can learn enough to break
different i think
different privacy may not hold i don't
know what attacks i can do
but
so i guess like how do you think about
the
yeah if
once covariates
okay well i guess my my question is um
uh
in order to replicate results i need to
know covariates i need to know the
design
but
these two are related and if the
covariates are private
how does this all play together have you
guys
i'm sure you've thought about this what
what are your thoughts on this yeah so
another fantastic question on the
practical aspect and also it also has
implication of method and theory too so
when we designed our coverage and asked
ask them for responses they were they
could respond in any any way they wanted
to say they could lie cheat
fake every because the thing at the end
of the day is when we proved our cover
adjusted estimator the model doesn't
matter and it will still be consistent
and so obviously if they provide more
honest things and if they could if if
you can model the the privatized
responses relation to the covariate that
they provided then we get more
efficiency out of it but doesn't mean
that you know they don't have to provide
us with you know complete honesty about
everything that we asked about the thing
and so and the second thing is actually
the design of the questions themselves
and so we went back and forth with the
irb about what kind of questions could
be asked and then even though they could
not even they don't have to answer to it
and as well and so
and i think that's a more of a
subject-specific or the
question-specific thing so we were able
to ask questions about like how many
courses that they take in about algebra
or see a computer science course and all
these other things but we i think
yeah there are some questions that we
weren't able to ask just because of uh
just constraints on our yeah but i think
there's a trade-off here because some
questions some covariates are highly
more predictive of whether you're going
to pay attention i'm not sure or not
than other cool things sure sure
um
thank you for your
response my second question i have more
following about we can talk after that
my second question is
um
as i've been learning more about
randomized control trials and when
people do them and and all the different
you know
ways and places these are done sometimes
i ask myself like why do we do this
why do we want to randomize control
trial like what did we
what knowledge did we gain
you know and here it's usually
statistical knowledge so we didn't have
beforehand from some other kind of means
i guess my question is
in the way that you're allowed to reveal
this in information like
you know there's all these studies
you you put up that said like
uh it's better to see the instructor's
face
and
like
using my own intuitive knowledge
i just know that to be true
and
you're like oh we can't replicate these
studies here so we're gonna like
do a control trial on our students
but you could just like ask them
you just ask like do you like this or
that and i don't know what incentive
they have to lie about that
so why did the department do this like
why is this a good id
what are they doing why why yeah that's
my question is why did they do this
experiment and what were they hoping to
gain that they didn't already
know or why did they not go with the all
turn alternate tips
uh so i i have to be careful here
because i'm currently in a uh yeah
i'm in promotional stages of my career
so uh
but no i mean just be clear the
department didn't uh force us to do it
nor and it was just a question that was
among covered in all of us or doing
instruction about having camera on
camera off because a lot of the some of
the students in wisconsin they're
actually doing it remotely and so they
can't even come to campus and some parts
of rural wisconsin don't have internet
connection and so there was a band of
issues that unfairness issues that came
up and then there was this general
discussion among the instruction
committee and ta committee about you
know what is the best way to still
deliver quality education while you know
and and what will be the effect of this
and how do we do this so yeah so that's
the general question and then we just
framed it we just provided a design
that and also my frustration was just
clinical trial getting individual
clinical trial data kind of coincided
and so we would provide a way to study
those type of questions but yeah by no
means the department didn't
force us to do it in order department
would be fine if you didn't do it
actually you might ask what why not just
ask the students
do you like video on do you like video
up that's so much easier than running a
patrol truck why did that not happen
yeah so we did also have those questions
not at the not even at the department
level but at the entire school level and
so and actually i i don't even know the
individual level results of that it's
only summary statistics are revealed so
actually there might even be better
opportunities to apply maybe not even
rct students but just differential
private local differential products
really to those survey results and
actually get so that we can actually
pull that observational data into
actually uh having a better estimate for
some of our model of things that maybe
we built but yeah i mean the the school
itself i'm sure other schools did this
too actually asked this question that
what they're encoded some online call
this semester yeah and so what we just
went a little bit further and we just
wanted to also see whether we can
actually do this and also i wanted my
student to actually learn how to collect
good data because if good data means
that it's easier for method attempted
orientation not many students and myself
included learn how to collect good data
we just know how to analyze data well
actually
so first of all i want to thank all the
speakers for uh three great talks so my
question is for emma um i guess at a
couple of places in your talk you sort
of hinted at causal inferences being
this two-stage process where we first
have to learn some kind of underlying
structure and then we do estimation of
effect
and
um as you said this machinery for sort
of rigorous causal estimation that you
presented is valid assuming that we are
given this
correct dag in the first place or cp dug
and so i guess my question is it's
related to a couple of questions that
we've already heard but i'm wondering if
there is still some notion of
statistical validity even if we have a
misspecified graph like of course there
are uh different kinds of graphs that
will give us the same kind of causal
effect for you know given causal
question but maybe some other causal
graphs are are still useful despite
being incorrect so i'm just wondering if
there is
still something that we can say like hey
you know i'm computing this causal
effect but it still has some form of
statistical validity in the context of
this graph for example i'm projecting
the true causal effect somehow in some
appropriate sense
to this you know toy approximation that
i've come up with and i think
that like there are a couple of reasons
why that's important like one reason is
definitely when
you know we're estimating dcp dots from
finite data but of course even if we
have domain knowledge you know there's
no guarantee that that domain knowledge
will actually spit out the correct graph
so i guess this is kind of a
philosophical question but i'm just
wondering is there still a way to think
about statistical validity if we're in
this uh mispassified setting
uh yeah thanks this is a complex
question so um
okay there's there's a few answers here
so i guess in some sense
right so learning the graph is tough and
generally things that we have don't
perform perfectly and
also don't perform well a lot of the
time
so what i would say to that is
two things so one is i guess you can see
the or i can think of an empty dag or
like this empty deck is like
you started with the dag and you've
removed some information right so you
can say like
i guess so in the in that sense like the
effect is identifiable regardless of
what orientations you have like on these
undirected edges so in a sense you're
kind of i guess to those mistakes you
are kind of you don't care about those
mistakes in terms of adding edges versus
removing edges
we don't have in this work results on
that that's has somewhat come up a
little bit
in work in the newer work with richard
but it's um it's by no means complete so
we can say like oh if you have this edge
present in addition to all the other
edges like nothing will be affected the
efficiency the consistency and so on
um
yeah so but
a lot more work is needed in that sense
i also know that there's like a lot of
you know people look at also like the g
formula and stuff and there's this this
other commentary on like well the g
formula really really requires a lot of
your graph to be correct right
whereas maybe this
some adjustment or some idea would just
need like the parents of certain notes
to be correct like you don't care about
the rest of the graph um so there are
certain like arguments of that what
we've seen in practice like even if you
estimate the graphs
uh this g formula approach does tend to
do better than than these parent
approaches so it seems that like there
is some
um i don't know that this still somehow
is helpful
but yeah i don't have a precise
quantification in terms of kind of the
two whole two-step thing and why do we
do this in two-step where we first learn
the graph and why don't we just kind of
directly learn some things there are
there's very little uh work on that
there's some really nice papers on this
like this
uh antner or expertise paper
that makes certain assumptions and then
they're able to do that directly
there's some of sophia's work that i
think is great
uh where she uses the graph more like a
tool but then just works
purely with data and has no kind of a
need to learn the graph directly but
yeah it's definitely an open problem and
i don't
i don't know like how much of the graph
can you kind of flop and still get the
correct answer yeah
i have two questions for niche and i
will do chris's procedure and ask one
after another
so the the first one
the first first yeah
um so the first one is slightly more
kind of
less conceptual and the second one is
conceptual
i don't remember what you called it but
basically that you can learn the
structure for the potential outcomes
that you don't the intervention
potential outcomes from the control
potential and pre-inspection period that
you can kind of the same structure i
don't remember what you call that
assumption but
i was thinking could you do like a type
of placebo test to test that assumption
where you try to
to replicate a unit that is a certain
treatment
and that you do observe and then you you
compare those two to time series the
artificial synthetic time series with
the absurd one
um
so just mississippi understood the
question so you're asking do you if you
hold out the data
of a patient uh that got therapy one and
how well you could recreate it
absolutely that's the first thing we
always do in all of these settings
um then you can see that the mean
squared error is like the r square is
relatively good
um and that's that's the the first thing
we do in all these settings is to ask
uh how well could we recreate it for
um
given therapy
if we held out you know 90 of the
patients but we still recreate them
and
a related answer to that question is
that how many patients do you need to be
able to recreate everyone
right so like why do we pick 50 for
example
in general we found that if the number
of patients you have is approximately
scaling is like
r square r cubed
where r is your estimated rank that
seems to be kind of the golden point
where it starts getting very accurate in
this cross validation sense so that's
kind of like the heuristic we generally
apply okay all right so the reason um
so you try to recreate the
expected time series right you have this
error term uh and but when you do the
comparison do that would be would you
would have that the area of the realized
expectation right yeah so i guess you
can only measure this when you're
averaging between different units but
your targets right are individual
treatment effects so you would the
validation exercise would be
with respect to an average yeah so the
two ways of doing it one is you average
over people for a given time step for
example or for a given person the
average over the entire
post invention okay so
both okay
exactly to get rid of the noise yeah um
so my worry in that case right is that
you would have some type of you you
would be
um
let's let's stop it the second question
is conceptual and let's return to my
questions during the talk and sorry for
interrupting you but
to me um
a randomized control trial is something
extremely precious
and
because it requires very few assumptions
and then
with the
while i really like it especially the
matrix completion view of center control
i really like it very sympathetic
they're considered stronger assumptions
right
to compare to vanilla rcts and if we can
estimate the marginal distributions of
all the potential outcomes without
making those assumptions what what does
this like
the tensor completion approach by us if
we have rct
well the
if you don't do any fancy stats on top
of the rct then what you're estimating
is for example the average
like some
you compute the distribution of the
people who got therapy one minus the
the distribution of people who got
therapy
the placebo and you look at that
difference right
but um that would hide for example if
there's some subpopulation that worked
really well on
right and so that's what we're trying to
do is that um
can we
this is exactly the problem is that the
average treatment effect here was was
negligible
and we were trying to still salvage this
this as you call a precious clinical
trial that um and see if we could find a
subpopulation that it works on
so
if the average treatment effect is
enough to make a decision then there's
no reason to do any of this but in many
settings it's it's not right i mean we
like to cover uh what's happening we run
a clinical trial for people about 65 and
we're on clinical trial for people
between 5 to 15 and so on and so forth
and it's not even clear that age is the
right way to be you know right way of
creating sub populations
and so the hope is that maybe this way
is is um can help you impute outcomes
for people who haven't tried it on
and maybe it just functions as a
recommendation system of which trials to
run because it's so expensive
and maybe that's kind of the way i think
it'll be the most useful at least in the
coming years is more just a
recommendation system of which popular
sub populations to try which therapies
are
yeah that makes sense thanks
okay so um thanks again to the three
wonderful talks um in this last session
let's give them another plot
thank you to all the speakers i think
for really really wonderful talks like
to this very broad audience of taking
this into account and just giving very
accessible talks for everyone i think it
has been really really
i'll
fun
it over yeah i just want to add to that
also thanks to all the great audience
who that's why we planned this panel
session to act and more people have a
dialogue instead of jesus speakers many
of you could have given talk to but we
couldn't have everyone so this is great
everybody had the chance to really
engage and take it down to the panel so
i really enjoyed it i'm kind of like a
little outsider but it's great
great
so thank you to everyone and i think
there is one more announcement for how
we're going to continue this week yes
tomorrow we have application uh vasilis
will give a talk uh on
[Music]
challenges and opportunities of
application of puzzle methods and
industry settings they're gonna meet at
10 am and the talk will be available on
zoom as well
[Music]
116 i guess
thank you that's great yeah
thank you very much you should give us
to all the staff support yeah
for those of you who are traveling home
have a safe trip i hope to see you
in the not so distant future
again yes
great thank you
everyone here